hi I'm staging screens lin-manuel
Miranda and I'd like to sing you a new
one act musical based on one sentence
one very long sentence spoken by Donald
Trump at a rally look having nuclear my
uncle was a great professor in scientist
and engineer dr. John Trump at MIT good
genes
very good genes okay very smart the
Wharton School of Finance very good very
smart you know if you're a conservative
Republican if I were a liberal it's like
okay if Iran is a liberal Democrat they
would say I'm one of the smartest people
anywhere in the world but when you're a
conservative Republican they try oh do
they do a number that's why I always
start off went Wharton was a good
student what their went there did this
bill to fortune you know I have to give
my like credentials all the time because
we're a little disadvantage what you
looked at the nuclear deal the thing
that really bothers me it would have
been so easy and it's not as important
as these lives are nuclear is powerful
my uncle explained that to me many many
years ago the power in that was 35 years
ago he would explain the power of what's
going to happen then he was right who
woulda thought but when you look at
what's going on with the four prisoners
now it used to be three now it's four
but when it was three and even now I
would have said it's all in the
messenger fellas and it is follows
because you know they don't they haven't
figured out that the women are smarter
right now than
and so you know is gonna take them about
150 years but the Persians are great
negotiators the Iranians are great
negotiators so they and they just can't
you just killed us end of sentence
[Applause]